[Musique]
l'entretien politique sur tv 78 dédié
ces dernières semaines aux élections
départementales et régionales merci de
nous rejoindre pour ce nouveau numéro je
reçois aujourd'hui othman nasri bonjour
bonjour et bienvenue vous êtes le
premier vice président sortant du
conseil régional d'île de france engagée
aux côtés de valérie pécresse vous
reggae a d'ailleurs un nouveau mandat
avec elle vous est numéro deux sur sa
liste dans les yvelines question pour
commencer dans le coeur du sujet
peut-être pas sur les régionales mais
sur votre famille politique vous êtes
bien toujours adhérent républicains
puisque vous êtes là vice président de
la fédération yvelinoise quand le numéro
2 de votre parti déclare marine le pen
n'est pas l'ennemie de la république ou
encore qu'il affirme vouloir créer une
justice exceptionnel sans appel possible
est ce que vous vous y retrouver encore
dans cette famille politique la famille
politique qui est celle de la droite
républicaine c'est la mienne et en
l'occurrence elle est bien illustrée par
ce qu'on fait à la région ile-de-france
valérie pécresse
on est extrêmement clair sur les sujets
de république et laïcité et en même
temps on est on incarne une droite qui
vit dans son époque n'hésite pas à
prendre en main des sujets comme la
transition écologique qui a surtout un
souci de résultat et de bonne gestion
et je crois que tout cela se voit
aujourd'hui en ile de france et quand on
est clair sur ce qu'on fait dans les
actes et pas simplement dans les grandes
déclarations
je crois que les électeurs s'y
retrouvent aussi mais je crois que la
droite républicaine existe encore et je
crois qu'on en a besoin mais c'est une
droite encore une fois qui est n'est
évidemment pas poreuse avec le
rassemblement national
quand vous la situation est claire pas
d'alliance avec le rassemblement
national pas de tractations pas de
discussion de rassemblement sous une
même bannière
en aucun cas en aucun cas et je crois
que l'élection de marine le pen à la
tête du pays serait une catastrophe pour
le pays et je crois que c'est pour ça
que la droite républicaine a une vraie
responsabilité et doit incarner encore
une fois des résultats concrets parce
qu'il ya une attente de nos concitoyens
aussi avec un sentiment d'insécurité qui
a énormément progressé dans notre pays
depuis quelques années est ce que vous
craignez pour l'avenir de votre famille
politique justement que les frontières
soient trop friable avec le
rassemblement national
et les républicains se penser à la
situation en paca aussi qui est bien
différente de celle de la région ile de
france
quand je vois les bilans de nos élus à
la tête de collectivités importante ici
à saint quentin en yvelines à la région
ile de france avec valérie pécresse
je n'ai pas de doute encore une fois sur
le fait la droite républicaine n'a rien
à venir et c'est encore une fois dans
les résultats concrets qu'on se rend
compte que est là ça a du sens encore
d'être de droite et qu' il y a beaucoup
d'électeurs qui ont besoin de cette
alternative et qui refusent un duel
entre emmanuel macron et marine le pen
et ça se voit bien dans nos territoires
et en ile de france je crois qu'on le
verra bien aussi à l'occasion de ce
scrutin
vous parlez d'ile-de-france et votre
candidate valérie pécresse elle elle
parle d'un autre radicalisme il ya un
vrai danger je la cite c'est de voir
arriver au pouvoir dans notre région une
gauche radicale qui a perdu sa boussole
républicaine
pourquoi cette analyse parce qu'on
constate qu'il y a des élus de gauche et
singulièrement les candidats à ces
élections régionales qui joue avec le
feu sur le sujet de la république et de
la laïcité ou qui par exemple aucun des
candidats des trois listes de gauche ni
monsieur bailly madame pulvar ni madame
autun n'est venu soutenir les policiers
quand manifester après le décès et les
blessures d'un certain nombre de leurs
collègues qui sont au prix pour cible en
raison de leur uniforme et on voit que
c'est une gauche qui cultive l'ambiguïté
sur tous ces sujets là on a tous en tête
les déclarations malheureuses grave de
madame pulvar qui a cautionné les
réunions non mixité il ya c'est une
réalité aujourd'hui une partie de la
gauche qui a perdu sa boussole
républicaine et qui pactisent qui a des
sympathies indigéniste racialiste qui
moi me pose problème et je ne veux pas
que les de france bascule entre les
mains de cette gauche extrême qui serait
une catastrophe pour la première région
de france
aujourd'hui valérie pécresse est en tête
dans les différents sondages selon les
projections en cas de second tour
c'est la gauche qui grimpent eux plus
tôt et qui en qui en profiterait en tout
cas jusqu'à présent
néanmoins il ya un autre adversaire et
pour le coup en ile de france c'est le
rassemblement national qui a fait de la
sécurité sa thématique prioritaire du
coup valérie pécresse et vous votre
liste répondait aussi à cette thématique
de sécurité mais la différence c'est que
nous n'exploitons pas les difficultés
nous essayons de les régler et en
l'occurrence on a quintuplé le budget
sécurité de la région ça représente 150
millions d'euros en cinq ans là où la
région ne faisait rien il y avait mille
agents pour sécuriser les transports
notamment mis la jante
sécurité supplémentaire dans les
transports en commun mais on a également
financé la vidéoprotection dans 333
commune différente plus de 300 police
municipale ont été équipés grâce aux
financements de la région et on est de
même aujourd'hui l'état à rénover et à
sécuriser les commissariats de police
nationale des casernes de gendarmerie on
l'a fait pour 80 deux opérations
différentes en ile de france c'est du
jamais vu et on est la région qui fait
le plus en matière de sécurité
simplement tout ce que je viens de vous
dire le rassemblement national ne l'a
pas votée en ile de france
ils nous ont refusé de voter notre
bouclier de sécurité donc je vois que il
ya des gens qui parlent d'insécurité
mais parce que c'est leur fond de
commerce et au moment où il ya des
solutions concrètes
ils ont la main qui tremble en ce qui
nous concerne a pris à bras le corps ce
sujet et naturellement on va continuer à
faire le maximum pour protéger les
franciliens dans la sécurité n'est pas
une des premières compétences entre la
région aussi tout même je le rappelle la
priorité est la compétence principale
plus tôt c'est la question des
transports en compte ce qui concerne les
transports depuis 2015 et l'arrivée de
valérie pécresse donc il ya succéder au
socialiste jean pollution quel bilan
vous faites on a engagé ce qu'on avait
dit à savoir la révolution des
transports avec la rénovation notamment
du matériel roulant
au moment où je vous parle cette année
650 rames neuves ou rénovées seront en
circulation en ile-de-france au total
c'est colossal
c'est exactement ce sur quoi nous nous
étions engagés et derrière encore une
fois je le redis puisque ce sujet de la
sécurité se décline dans les transports
ce sont des rames vidéoprotégé ce sont
des rames climatisé et on est en train
d'investir massivement dans les
transports en commun parce qu'il y avait
c'est vrai un sous-investissement
chronique dans les transports pendant
les dix-sept années précédentes
et donc aujourd'hui on va continuer à
mettre le paquet sur les transports à
l'avenir ça veut dire le grand paris
express le doublement du réseau de
transport en commun en ile-de-france que
la région évidemment porte fortement
on va continuer à investir par exemple
dans les bus vous savez qu'on nous avons
renforcé 900 lignes de bus que nous
sommes en train de décarbonés toute la
flotte de bus en ile-de-france et qu' il
n'y aura plus de bus diesel dans la zone
urbaine à partir de 2025 des bus propres
des transports 9 des transports modernes
c'est cela dont on a besoin et ça
demande des financements naturellement
et jamais la région n'a autant investi
24 milliards d'euros au total sur les
transports en commun en ile-de-france et
des transports en commun totalement
gratuits comme le propose
audrey pulvar je pense que c'est prendre
les électeurs pour des idiots que de
parler de gratuité des transports
d'abord ça coûterait 4 milliards d'euros
il faut bien que quelqu'un les paye ses
4 milliards pour
tourner les transports en commun ça
représente une hausse d'impôt de 500
euros par foyer franciliens donc ce que
nous prépare un d'un pulvar si par
malheur elle était élue c'est évidemment
la ruine des transports en commun
puisque on a besoin de financement je
viens de l'expliquer et puis la hausse
massive des impôts en ile de france
il ne faut pas faire cette gratuité qui
en plus n'a aucun impact écologique on a
fait des études indépendantes elles
disent toutes la même chose
seuls 2 % des automobilistes prendrait
les transports en commun si les
transports étaient gratuits on le
comprend bien on prend pas sa voiture
parce que les transports sont trop chers
surtout quand les employeurs prennent en
charge la moitié donc il ya un reste à
charge de 36 ou 37 euros par mois une
voiture coûte beaucoup plus cher
ce qu'il faut c'est investir sur les
transports pour qu'il y ait des
alternatives et que ceux qui le peuvent
puisse laisser leur voiture dépasse de
parking par exemple que nous nous
concentrons fait 8000 en ile de france
pour prendre les transports en commun
mais des transports en commun de qualité
qui nécessite donc des investissements
et pas la paupérisation proposé par
madame pulvar
je reviens sur un autre sujet en 2018
donc avant la pandémie
près d'un francilien sur deux déclaré
vouloir quitter l'île de france
pas seulement pour la question des
transports pour une question de qualité
de vie aussi et d'ailleurs on l'a vu
pendant la pandémie
il ya eu beaucoup de parisiens qui ont
quitté qui ont découvert la grande
couronne cette fois ci notamment les
yvelines vous leur dites quoi tous ces
franciliens qui souhaitent quitter la
région pour le territoire reste
attractif
je veux déjà à tordre le cou à une idée
reçue ile de france ne perd pas
d'habitants on a cinquante mille
personnes
en plus tous les ans l'île de france le
seul territoire qui perd des habitants
c'est paris et on sait dans quel état
est géré la ville de paris aujourd'hui
on sait par qui d'ailleurs elle est
gérée et effectivement la ville de paris
et perd un certain nombre d'habitants
tous tous les ans mais c'est le cas
uniquement de paris le reste de
l'ile-de-france où venait de lire gagne
des habitants et même de manière
significative et c'est pour ça qu'on a
investi massivement par exemple dans la
ruralité
parce qu'il ya un désir de vivre à la
campagne aujourd'hui est que les
territoires ruraux étaient les grands
oubliés de la gestion de la région
c'est pas compliqué on a deux millions
de ruraux en ile de france et un sixième
de la population nous leur consacrons
désormais un sixième des investissements
avec du transport à la demande nous en
ferons nous ferons 40 réseaux de
transport à la demande supplémentaire
dans la prochaine mandature nous avons
pris des engagements très forts avec des
contrats ruraux pour réinvestir aussi
sur les commerces de proximité sur le
patrimoine sur les équipements sportifs
on a financé 1200 en ile de france hier
encore j'étais à bonnières pour visiter
un gymnase que la région a financé
encore une fois dans la ruralité parce
que c'est là où il ya effectivement
beaucoup d'habitants qui qui veulent
s'installer et c'était des territoires
qui étaient complètement oublié par la
bvk précédente majorité de gauche
donc moins il investit massivement et je
crois que ça contribue effectivement à
l'attractivité de lait de france mais
c'est un sujet évidemment parmi d'autres
on investit sur le logement aussi bien
sûr massivement et sur tous ces sujets
là jamais la région n'avait autant était
efficace et encore une fois avec
pragmatisme loin de toute idéologie mais
je le redis les de france gagne 50 mille
habitants marrant c'est la ville de
paris qui perd ses habitants et on
comprend bien quand on voit la sécurité
et la pollution que qu'on a aujourd'hui
à paris oui alors après vous parlez
plusieurs sujets en donnant les réponses
que vous apportez vous parler de la
question de la sécurité d'abord
cette insécurité elle touche aussi au
delà de paris on l'a vu dans le
département des yvelines il y aussi les
des réponses à y apporter
puis vous parlez de 50000 habitants
nouveau en ile de france dans une
certaine mixité aussi parce qu'on quitte
aussi cette région parce que c'est cher
tout simplement pour y vivre dans le
département des yvelines aussi bien sûr
c'est pour ça qu'on finance par exemple
des logements qui sont aussi réservés à
certaines professions qui ont énormément
de mal à se loger des gens qui se
battent en première ligne comme on dit
aujourd'hui dont on a besoin
je pense par exemple aux professionnels
de santé on finance des logements
réservés aux infirmières dont on a
besoin en ile-de-france qui sont
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont beaucoup de mal à
se loger en ile-de-france on finance on
réserve des logements régionaux pour des
enseignants aussi dans les quartiers les
plus difficiles où on a besoin
d'enseignants de qualité donc on essaye
là aussi d'apporter une réponse soit
pouvoir d'achat des franciliens je vous
rappelle que le pass navigo a été gelée
et c'est la première fois que ça se fait
pendant trois années consécutives et
c'est tout à fait normal pour préserver
le pouvoir d'achat des franciliens je
vous rappelle qu'on a fait le demi tarif
pour les personnes âgées de plus de
soixante deux ans qui sont souvent en
ile-de-france aussi dans des situations
financières difficiles on m'a fait le
pass navigo junior aussi à 2 euros par
mois pour les enfants de 4 à 11 ans
soulager les parents qui peuvent du coup
les prendre dans les transports en
commun prendre leurs enfants avaient
avec eux et donc il ya une politique
globale et qu'ils expliquent pour
argument simple c'est qu'on l'a fait des
économies dans la gestion de la région 2
milliards d'euros d'économies sur les
dépenses de fonctionnement qu'on redonne
aux franciliens avec tous les
dispositifs dont je vous parlais et
encore une fois sans jamais avoir
augmenté les impôts une dernière
question j'ai lu que si valérie pécresse
n'était pas réélu elle mettrait fin à sa
carrière politique est ce que vous y
croyez pas je crois qu'avec le bilan qui
est le sien à la région ile de france et
tout le monde s'accorde à dire que le
travail qui a été fait est un travail
colossal que la région est aujourd'hui
identifiées et bien géré et on l'a vu
pendant la crise sanitaire est entré
dans le quotidien des franciliens avec
des actions extrêmement concrètes pour
chaque francilien pour tous les
territoires
mais je crois que si ce bilan on n'était
pas valorisé et que sa vision pour l'île
de france n'était pas reconnu
c'est normal qu'elle qu'elle se pose
cette question mais je pense que les
électeurs encore une fois voudront que
la région continue sur de bons rails
donc que cette question ne se posera pas
est ce que dans un coin de sa tête
quitte questions supplémentaires il ya
la présidentielle ou pas qu'on vous
dirigez la première région de france
vous ne pouvez pas être insensible à ce
qui se passe dans le reste du pays est
là ce qu'elle a fait en ile de france on
est nombreux à penser qu'il ya des
choses qui peuvent être utiles pour tout
le pays on l'a vu sur la sécurité sur le
pouvoir d'achat sur l'investissement sur
la bonne gestion de la région ile de
france est donc naturellement qu'elle
aura une parole pour pour la situation
nationale du pays mais je vous prie
croire qu'aujourd'hui elle à 100% sur la
région ile-de-france franz a sévi depuis
cinq ans dans le cadre d'une primaire
s'est ouvert la primaire avant quitte
personnel moi je souhaite une primeur
parce que je souhaite qu'il y ait un
candidat unique de la droite qui
viennent casser le duel entre emmanuel
macron et marine le pen
mais ça on verra je pense après les cas
on aura l'occasion d'en parler bien sûr
merci othman naciri mercian a donc dans
les yvelines pour cette régionale 2021
en ile de france sur la liste de valérie
pécresse et la fin de cet entretien
politique on se retrouve bientôt sur tv
[Musique]